[Music]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey
that loves
[Music]
so you don't start the day drinking
coffee no
really no i really don't i i don't like
when i wake up i don't like to eat or
drink anything until my body's like
you're going to pass out really it's
probably not healthy i know it's not
healthy so you know we all know it's not
healthy but you intermittent fat no no
that's what intermittent fasting is
intimate fasting is saying because
that's what breakfast means break the
fast so when did you know that stop it
now
swear to god i see you because it makes
you just blew my mind because it makes
very much sense that's what it means i
swear
i swear to god you didn't just make it
up no breakfast means break fast and
it's the term that means you're breaking
the fast because you from not eating
from the day before and that's what
intermittent fasting basically
intermittent fasting's whole thing is is
when we were hunters and gatherers you
wouldn't you would only eat and you
would only graze on stuff you would only
eat big meals when you hunted and killed
it so they're saying that's why you
should only you should you don't really
need to eat all the time like it's a
luxury that's why we have obesity and
all these problems because our bodies
are not designed to eat like that but
that's what breakfast is breaking the
fast from the night before but then they
spelled but then but you know
that's what it is it's break fast yeah
but i i it makes so much sense and it's
never crossed my mind
so what is lunch
lunch is
let's go through them pimpy what is like
yeah what what what's lunch mean
lunch where did the term lunch come from
etymology maybe babe
could you let's have pimp spell
etymology imagine he nails it
lunch according to the oxford oh it's on
they're uncertain
no yeah it says it
oh are mysterious and complicated
lunch was a very well
very rare word up until the 19th century
one theory is that it derived from the
word
nunchian well what about luncheon
isn't the luncheon
yeah
ah my allergies well back in the england
and all medieval times they would call
it a nunchuck so you wouldn't have lunch
you would have nunchucks you wouldn't
have lunch when we go to england should
we just say um we're here for lunch i am
starving are you guys open for lunch are
you overwhelming lunch i just want to
have a i just want a nunch on something
yeah
yeah i had a mug
you guys want to eat dinner at six i
can't i had a big lunch
what is dinner
rain dine dying
dinner is dine
dinner and you know linner is an
official term too linner lunch dinner
it's official it's official term i
thought it was slang but i think it's
actually an official term and and it's
and uh also liger
is an animal that exists yes that's true
i didn't know that either they always
have heart problems
really they're like they have like down
syndromes no seriously that's when a
lion and a tiger do it when a lion and a
tiger do it but i want to line a tiger
do it that's when they do it but that's
the equivalent of like an animal down
syndrome it's like the same chromosomal
thing when the lion bangs the tiger it's
not it's not native to nature wow
yeah liger lions and tigers are
separated by about seven million years
of evolution didn't know that no clown
exist only in captivity because the
habitats of the parental species do not
overlap in the world there's no proof
that ligers have ever existed you can
make anything you can made any you can
mate any animal with any other animal
but i know this is i know i know really
our dna
the thing is with dna
is is what's the thing with dna
first of all shallow cricket and helix
those are the guys that made they
discovered dna shadow quickening okay
sometimes you'll drop you're like
rolling the rolling who
and then you're like shout out qriket
and helix the guys who are responsible
yeah dionova tribe at clay gas
i think that's how you say it
but the thing with dna the thing with
dna
yes monkeys are having monkeys with deer
monkeys aren't having sex with deer why
do they do that the thing is the dna is
we have a code so let's say i make it
simple let's say the human code is zero
zero zero zero zero one two three four
but then the code of a pig is zero zero
zero zero zero one three four two so so
we're only ever a couple of numbers away
from being an animal so there are
certain dnas that you can mix certain
ones it's just not gonna work but
technically i think if you like somehow
we're able to like i don't know bang a
parrot right you might be able to cons
it might there's a chance of it
conceiving i believe it would have
happened
with all these people on earth eight
billion people the percentage of those
people are deviants i feel like somebody
would have tried to stick it in a parrot
already it's maybe you're right but but
i do know that cricket cricket and is it
cricket and helix but any what is that
that was a donkey zebra i look like a
donkey a zebra and let's say on this
yeah a zonkey they call it
i would have called it a d bruh deborah
a deborah
they should change zebra and donkey to
zeb to deborah from brazil
it's called a donkey but listen if
you're name if you're a debra
that looks like a dab bro look at her
what would that insinuate because that
thing is adorable
literally that thing is amazing i mean
if that thing trotted in this room right
now
oh my god i'd want to like punch it but
not to hurt it yeah just like how you
want to punch a baby yeah
i'd immediately i'd immediately i'd
immediately start
if that thing i'm telling you if that
thing walked into the room i would
immediately start making out with debra
right away i was just tongue kissed ever
right there i mean look at her it's a
zebra and a donkey yeah it's got a bit
of a big crane cranium i like it though
what else do we got we got a jaglion a
male jaguar plus a female iron which
just looks like a
jaguar no that thing looks
really weird yeah what are the eyes in
that thing the eyes of that thing are
scaring me right now a jaguar look look
at the eyes it's staring right through
us wow a male jaguar plus a female lion
a jaguan i would have called it a laugh
it looks like that looks straight up
demonic straight up that's scarier to me
than any singular jaguar
or lion yeah look at the right photo it
is it is terrifying i would have called
it a laguar like that sounds like it
sounds like a spanish infinitive
yeah
that's fun
it looks like it's got all different
parts of animals just glued to it looks
like a
it
franken
like crazy that's wild even it's like it
looks like a stuffed animal that someone
propped up i would go if that was my
animal i would go beep beep who got the
keys to the geep
wow a groller
[Laughter]
a
bear
bear
plus a brown bear a groller bear
is that a grizzly bear plus a polar bear
but it says brown bear yeah cause it
should be a broller bear or a brown bear
should be a brown bear or a bowler bear
yeah or a broller bear a groller bear i
wonder how those do you know the most
vicious one is the polar out of all the
bears oh it was a grizzly
i thought chris grizzy's got the worst
that's craziest name yeah you're right
but i heard polar is a not to be effed
with polar not do you know i've got a
real nice pr team going with them with
coca-cola right during the holidays yeah
the high holies yeah but like i heard
that they are vicious and will tear you
apart yeah and there you go yeah
you're asian yeah and yeah a coy wolf
a coy wolf a coy wolf coyote plus wolf
which just actually just that looks like
a wolf to me i would i would have called
it a royote
a woyody's a nice one
there is a clear thing here the team of
people that were caught up with these
names always went for the the less fun
name yeah it's like obviously the
deborah is the one
did you just see this
this is a whale
a male false killer where plus a female
bottlenose dolphin a wolf and i stand
corrected that's the best one that was
like don't worry we'll get you a wall
because but calling it a dale would be
funny
oh what is a wolf in a whale and so
that's got to be messed up when a
dolphin's just like yeah the whale comes
up behind the dolphin is like guess what
yes it's a woman
[ __ ] i'm not asking a buffalo plus a cow
is called the beefalo
i guarantee you we've eaten we've eaten
beefalo burgers before there's no way we
haven't eaten beefalo wait how do you
isn't a buffalo a male isn't a cow
female and a
a bull is
yeah isn't that just gonna go through
this whole a.m but isn't a buffalo a
bull
yeah
also it's also called a catalog oh my
god a beefalo is the funniest thing a
beefalo a beefalo
burger um bull and buffalo are two
animals that show difference between
them in terms of their nature and
characteristics
bull is the male species of the cattle
of the cow buffalo gives milk whereas
bill bull does not
so so oh they're saying so the buffalo
if a buffalo has sex with a cow it's a
beefalo
so a buffalo gives milk a bowl
have you ever had buffalo milk have you
ever heard of that no buffalo milk
no i've only ever even been to buffalo
new york twice
who who is uh
so if you're an animal
it's just up to which we are by the way
right yeah
but but if you're an animal you're not
human it's just up to you
what you decide to
to have sex with
yeah i mean but if that was true
wouldn't it be just we couldn't even
keep track of the animals if every
animal if if one lone beefalo
what about when a beefalo
has sex with like a wolfen if a beefalo
had sex with a wolf and that would be
chaos that's another podcast
what's up got big news we got september
17th and 18th fort lauderdale i'm coming
september 24 to the 26th irvine improv
los angeles area almost sold out the
first show on october 23rd at foxwoods
is sold out only tickets available for
the second show and big big news we got
the wilbur theater in boston on sale
right now november 21st laugh boston
november 18th to the 20th all sold out
wilbur theater we've added sunday night
christy comedy.com november 21st thank
you so much i love you all right cute
kids come see me in austin september
24th at the paramount theater that's for
the moon tower comedy festival uh i will
be headlining there and then the next
day september 25th i will be in denver
at the bellco theater with david spade
and frank caliendo for charity uh all
ticket to salvocanocomedy.com and then
i'm on tour with the guys this tour has
started it's an arena tour i'll tell you
the first weekend uh glendale arizona
san diego california and sacramento
california those are the first big dates
but all dates are up and they're at the
tenderloins.com
tour like
because the beefalo could do whatever he
or she wants after they get born too so
now you got now you got
someone that's not supposed to be here
right like nate naturally naturally and
they
are going to have relations with another
animal that's not supposed to be here
what happens
see what i don't i don't know i don't
know if see that might be one we have to
obviously i'd have to we'd have to talk
to qriket but but the dna guy but by can
you google if that's i i think i might
be doing it wrong who created dna but do
you do you have i think that that might
be too many jumps because you can go too
many jumps so that might not take yeah
francis crick i looks calling him
cricket but it's crack
can and it's my my shirt okay
can any by the way that was only in the
50s right because before that nobody was
solving cold cases no dna was first
identified in the late 1860s by swiss
chemist friedrich maestro but they
didn't have dna testing until cricket
and watson that's all remember that that
that that dock on netflix called the the
like the strangler or whatever the
it's on now it's like uh
uh it's a dock about a serial killer
from san diego
oh yeah i caught him using footprints
dude footprints because dna was not
either street no oh the nightstalker
nightstalker yes that's it 1986 dn the
other mets won the world series dna
fingerprinting was first used in a
police forensic test in 1986 two
teenagers had been raped and murdered in
narboro leicester
leicestershire
listershire in 1983 and 1986
respectively respectively although the
attacks had occurred three years apart
similarities led the police to believe
that one person was responsible for
three
page five both what
all right hold on a second i don't know
what's happening dna fingerprinting
wasn't used until 80 i was 10 years old
yeah i could have gotten away with any
crime no but i also feel like that
should have been huge news when i was
10. no like when i was 10 i remember
playing like cops and robbers or
whatever and looking for fingerprints
yeah
but it was new technology the
the media picks and chooses what they
want to make a big splash about in 1986
you picture that story coming out like
attention if you touch something yeah
they could track it back to you now yeah
everybody must be like wait what what
yeah yeah that's huge news huge news
yeah i think i think um
it's interesting because now and it's
even further now now
you can even get if your dna is in any
date your dna doesn't even have to be in
a database even if they just have like a
partial match if your family member like
let's say your great uncle killed
somebody and then you
did the dna you know 23 and me thing
yeah your it would go go into this big
world database and the computers could
just figure it out if it matched a
partial print that they had from your
great uncle connect to your products
they would get nabbed from that victory
that's how all these people are getting
caught is because it's because one of
their family members so if you've
committed a crime out there do not have
your family do 23 and me yeah did you
ever do it you did because you found
that yeah found out mostly german and
then they always tell me i got a new
relative but then you got to pay to find
out who the new relative is no thank you
it's [ __ ] i don't care if i don't
know you now if i haven't if i've been
going this long without you i don't need
you babe yeah 100 i don't need you yeah
and so uh yeah so i don't drink coffee
uh when i wake up and yes
you don't drink coffee
and you know what i started doing again
you know i started doing i started
eating bacon
started eating bacon are you going to
keto now no i'm eating bacon with bread
i just started eating bacon
i just got back in the bacon i don't
know what happened
i just said they said wait the pigs are
the smartest animal they know that
they're being killed and eaten and i
said you know i'm smarter than you yeah
me and you okay you know which is wrong
of me but i'm not eating cheese which is
interesting people keep pigs as pets uh
now more and more
i'm gonna probably get off bacon again
at some point everyone eats it i mean
what are we doing a ham and cheese
sandwich
here's right
i'm being honest with you i don't think
i've had a cold-cut piece of ham
15-20 years oh i love a ham sandwich i'm
not i haven't even had i don't even i've
i'm not a cold-cuts guy i'm i'm not
christy call cuts at all i'm not if i
was going to go to a deli if i was going
to go to delhi i don't i go first of all
i'm the kind of guy that i will go
now it used to be if you talked to me a
week ago it would be avocado egg and
cheese on a roll 24 hours a day
if you don't have avocado i would say
just egg and cheese ketchup
now i'll go bacon and egg no cheese on a
roll with ketchup 24 hours a day if i'm
not in the mood for that i'll go toast a
bagel with butter whenever or i'll
always do this i'll go with tuna fish
sandwich on whole wheat wow from any
deli it doesn't matter i'll go to a i'll
go to any deli and get tuna fish a lot
of people don't like to risk that i'll
do it man i'll do it i'll do it the only
thing i won't risk is oysters i won't do
oysters if you really think about what
you're doing you won't do oysters no
never had them no i don't know why it's
just yeah
yeah my girlfriend took me to an oyster
bar for my birthday i didn't i didn't
eat the oysters i i do it i play the
part i have oysters you put the little
like
little vinegar in there put a little
little lemon in there a little tabasco
you can get destroyed by that though you
need a bad oyster i know i never have
knocked on wood thank god but yeah but
but then you taste those things and you
just swallowed something then i was like
swallowing them without like chewing
them because i thought that's what
you're supposed to do and then someone
was like no i chew mine so recently i
chewed a few of them oh yeah when you
just swallow it doesn't it feel like
you're swallowing a loogie it probably
it kind of does dude
yeah i don't know again i just show up
and i'm like let's do this
like i don't know it's
totally you should have oysters at the
live show that the people are going to
see next week
i know i should have given the front row
oysters oh so yeah yeah i know we did
the live show the three live shows are
in the bank they're in the back two
maybe three
you're gonna see one next week with the
live hey babe we're gonna release as an
episode so you guys can see what we did
how about that and because we just go to
the idea how about this we got even
better news october 1st at the lyric in
baltimore sal and i will be doing
co-headlining both doing stand-up and
then coming out at the end and maybe
doing a couple of minutes of a question
and answer mini hey babe but it's a
stand-up show and why don't we give the
first row of that crowd oysters we'll do
it should we do that should we cater
oysters and get it for him let's do it
i'll show you so you got to go to uh
either
salvocanocomedy.com yeah or christy
comedy.com and get the tiki wikis or the
lyricbaltimore.com yeah and october 1st
i also think that north carolina should
be looking out for an announcement they
should be looking out for announcement
if you're live in the durham north
carolina area or anywhere in the south
just keep just put a pin in october 29th
that's all i'll say that's all we're
saying
and i'll we're coming to durham is the
other other thing i'll say
but i won't tell you the venue the
second city has been named uh yeah keep
an eye out for keep an eye on that but
um you know if you really if you're
thinking about when you walk into a deli
what what tuna fish is because they put
like in that in that tray that they make
it in that tuna fish has got to be like
a i would call that a 15 pound tray
right right it's shredded tuna insides
mixed with mayonnaise
and it's it's putting a 15 pound
pile of muck
they chop up a little celery in there
maybe and then they put it in a fridge
and and and you've seen this happen well
no i mean what are you talking about
it's just i'm just told mom you worked
in a deli i did it you did it so how
what was what was this process tuna
that's generally could be off-putting to
begin with and there's also something
about mayo that's generally off-putting
to begin with and so too when you
combine those two it's very a polarizing
very polarizing sandwich
i think a tuna fish and to go into any
old deli
sometimes sometimes i gotta be i i like
it too in a sandwich but then sometimes
if you think about what it is like and
tuna tuna the expiration dates on a tuna
can you ever see
like 10 years right yeah so what has
what does that mean that's a that's a
albacore that died a decade ago yeah
that you're putting on white bread with
mayonnaise oh so you don't eat tuna fish
ever you don't like tuna no i i don't
mind it but i got to eat in the mood
what's the same thing with a hot dog i
mean we talked about it before in the
show i mean hot dog's more disgusting
than tuna i know
yeah i mean that's i mean
oh god joe de rosa slept over there
wasn't just a look from his channel
slept over in the studio
oh god dude you don't look that bad man
in the morning you look pretty good in
the morning yeah i think so dude
wow you actually did just wake up
because it looks like you get you just
woke up yeah i did he's got a great hit
joey's got great hair yeah but i mean do
you know what it's like to wake up to
europe
oh to chrissy dee's voice just screaming
oh that first i heard you say was you
were comparing yourself to pig dna
i was like somewhere derose's ears are
ringing oh yes
yes
it's the same dude what are you guys
talking about dna we're talking about um
any animal could bang any animal they
want and then you just call them a cute
new name really yeah yes oh
what is a wolf and a dolphin a wolfen
a whale on a dolphin a whale and a dog a
wolfen is a wolfen uh uh a zebra a zebra
and a lion they call no zebra donkey you
see you bring a donkey they call it
zonkey but we would call it a debra
um
or debra and the buffalo and the
buffalo in a cow it's called a beefalo a
beefalo
and a goat in the sheep is a geep
no joke
wait no you're joking right no no no
this is what we look like we're looking
at them too
we were looking up look at that's a
beefalo a waffen
wait did they make a baby yeah some
animals can i was i was i was trying to
put forward to fear that even a human i
said if you could have sex with a parent
you can make a human parrot but that's
false
i mean do they have to be in the same
category like
how skinny joe's legs are it just
dude
what are you doing
what am i doing what are you doing
i'm not doing leg exercises dude what do
you mean what's what's better what are
you doing it's it's noon it's wake up
dude we went to bed really late last
what time dude we went to
we were at uh we met up with uh
can i tell you okay we met up with q
yes brian quinn
last night to work on an idea for
something
and just didn't even open the computer i
mean just
we didn't just drank it had a good time
five seconds on it but it was a fun
night it was a great night yeah we just
we ordered a bunch of hoagies and
watched the fights
like and just drank
you know what but you need that
you didn't drink no why not
i just didn't you know he wakes up and
doesn't drink coffee he drinks coffee
later in the day really he doesn't start
eating both of you guys the coffee that
in the beginning of the day if i don't
start with coffee i can't even function
all three of you coffee start you think
like you just woke up you're gonna have
coffee within the next 20 minutes you
have to i mean i do want to have one but
i mean i don't know if you've ever seen
that machine down there dude it's it's
not easy to use no no i i can't you guys
have to be well versed on that machine
jasmine's down there she can do it women
can do it
she just knows how to do it you think
jasmine just has an internal
breville manual in her head i guarantee
you jasmine can can put that on for you
and do it women just know how to i
guarantee you jasmine can make that
coffee really she's down there right now
i bet you jazz you could do it right
oh wow how much am i getting paid right
now i don't ask de rosa
he'll give you a tuna fish sandwich
from derose's heart eight i'll give you
free sauce
no i just want you to i'm just saying as
a woman i bet you can put on that coffee
machine i i don't think as a woman just
a general matter of course should even
like be the be words that come at her
anymore we can't do it well we can but i
just think that people will take it and
make it whatever they want like for
instance you're just saying because
she's a woman she knows how to make a
coffee i little i was actually the
credit the actually what i was saying is
is a woman she's smarter i was saying a
woman is smarter than us and she would
be able to figure that out right a lot
quicker than we could you knew i knew
what you were saying that's what i'm
trying to say
it's like one of those buzz things as a
woman and then they're gonna think
you're right i don't think that's what
you were saying i want no that's what i
meant oh let's go on the phones let's go
that's what i meant i said
i think that it's
as a woman i'm saying i think she can
look at that machine and actually figure
it out quicker than i have because the
women have more power and you have to
understand how much women have women
came about how are they coming out a
wombat and a
this man like this sounds like at the
end of the you sound like the trainer at
the at the end of the jake paul fight
last night what was he doing no not the
jake paul one the one where the two
women fought uh the the woman who won
toronto and mercado yeah her trainer was
going he goes what do you think of the
opponent he goes look mexicans are
supposed to be great fighters
we were expecting a great fight from a
mexican
it was like he was like i guess he was
trying to say elementary but
he was like a big like beefy like like
like bald-headed like like bro and it
just didn't sound right
he's like usually a mexican doesn't back
down yeah and we we thought that this
mexican would back and it was like why
do you just call her by
[Laughter]
you guys have fun i'm going to go
downstairs go downstairs and have her
make the coffee dude yeah yeah and then
have her [ __ ] whip you something up
because because because so intelligently
because she's she's a very good cook you
know and if she gets out of line no i
don't get it
if she gets actually yeah
jasmine's the kind of person i'm i'm you
know she'd hit me before right yeah i
would love to see her knock you the [ __ ]
out to you
yeah that would be that would be a
pay-per-view for me that would be yeah i
would do that now 99.99 pay-per-view
yeah just get some like 10 ounce gloves
she's a lefty too dude so she would
catch me and just knock my head off
we should videotape that like just you
have to just stand there like like a
jackass thing like you can just let her
like slush
my daughter's a lefty tooth dude because
sometimes my door will come by but
because she's a south pole she'll just
catch me in the nuts with a quick jab
but she was because because you always
block the right
wait
she just it's a thing for her to just
literally use your nuts like a puncher
she runs she runs by her brother too and
just slaps in the back of the head all
the time yeah see you later joey d
20 20 to 30 of coffee farms are operated
by women by the way around 5 million of
the estimated 25 million coffee
producers worldwide are women so seventy
percent to eighty percent of male 1 well
you don't know if they could be they
could be uh transgender as well right
right that's not you don't know what you
know i would say what if 30 of coffee
farms are ran by transgender people you
don't know it could be even stephen babe
yes i did co-pilot i did that that
fitness app i was telling you about i
had the call with the trainer first of
all hot diesel guy it was great i was
breathing heavy on you that's not even
one of the things they tout but the
people that you're going to talk to are
just gorgeous peeps yeah it's 100 remote
okay 100 remote control it's literally a
fitness app where they ever it's
unbelievable because they hold you
accountable getting in shape and getting
ripped and getting rid of my puffy
nipples it's all about being held
accountable yeah and
co-pilot holds you accountable you work
out on your own schedule so whatever
your schedule may be you want to work
out four o'clock in the morning yeah
workout at four o'clock in the morning
yeah it doesn't matter you have four or
five you could do four four f i have to
check if i don't know if the app can do
but there's gonna be a diesel guy held
with me 100 diesel guy or girl whatever
you want yeah and it's one-on-one
personal training one-on-one personal
training usually costs one at least a
hundred dollars yes easy a hundred
dollars a session yeah co-pilot costs 69
per month 69
69 per month for unlimited they're hot
people yeah what if i want to work out
of 420
for unlimited 911 was an inside job for
unlimited coaching and training it's not
just a great product it's also a great
price it really truly is 69 listen for
69 a month you can get on the phone with
a hot guy or girl and work out a little
bit christine actually did kill himself
yes go pilot let's see how they get the
discount for their babes we got to give
the babes a discount where is it if you
go to my
copilot.com
hey babe that's
mycopilot.com hey babe you get 14 days
of free training that's two weeks of
free training what's the worst that can
happen you lose a little bit of weight
yeah that's the worst i can have a
little bit of puffiness that's all that
could happen to you go to my copilot.com
hey babe screenshot pictures of your
trainer let's rate how hot they are
could be even steven what kind of coffee
do you do you indulge in cafe busello
oh wow the yellow the old school oh
that's strong i got cafe bustelo
that's what i like i like kevin fustello
or
or i well i like the coffee from home
you do bustelo at home i'll do bestello
in a keurig i do like to call i like a
french roast i mean when you push it all
down like that i do like i like to drip
um chrissy drip drop i like i also like
um the coffee right by here by the
studio a couple blocks away i like it i
like that coffee a lot and i like that
croissants but if i'm home if i'm home i
typically
i like here's the thing i like keurigs i
like the catholic bustelo keurig but i
do feel now that i actually own an
actual house i got i ca i gotta have
something better get yourself a coffee
pot christmas gift maybe for me yeah
yeah i like that a lot oh i like that a
lot
you don't know what stormy gift
nothing you need you need
i got i'm gonna get you the the do you
want to want to roast them fresh yes
grind the beans fresh put them in a
thing like that like jazz are you good
with grinding the beans fresh
can you figure that out no it's just a
little thing it's simple jazz thing i
have downstairs you want that you guys
want that yeah all right
she's not answering is she okay jazz are
you okay
oh you're reading sorry all right well
we're getting you a coffee bean machine
that's what it's called puerto ricans
should know how to make coffee just like
the trailer a coffee bean coffee
grandfather uh used to wake up every
morning and he used to just put he the
way he made his call he was wild when he
had a little tin it almost looked like a
little tin
uh kettle yes i know exactly what that
is it was just like
like like almost like steel or something
and and he just put he had this like uh
it almost looked like a fishing net like
a net
it was like had a wooden handle with
like a net on it okay and he would just
put
actual ground coffee in that and it was
like you know thick enough that it
wouldn't fall through and then he would
just steep it
in the kettle for the whole day like
he'd put it on just leave it there it
was like bla i mean when the darkest of
dark dark days he would just drink it
all day and he would just pour it out
but it would be steeping all day long
really yeah and so the stove was on the
entire day he would like i don't know i
guess he would heat it or whatever it is
but i remember when he would pour it out
it was like you could smell coffee to
the house for the whole day awesome
smell though it was so good i woke up
every day with like smelling with that
smell i still don't drink coffee like
that but wow it's just for me it's like
because because the thing is i didn't
really even start drinking coffee until
i was like
25 which is late not until graduate
school oh me too and i lived my whole
life without it and then once i started
drinking it for literally two days i now
i'm i cannot live without it that's wild
which is bad i mean it's not good i
thought when i was little i thought it
was like kids shouldn't have coffee
that's what i thought no is that the
truth no well in america but in europe
the kids drink coffee all day yeah they
drink it and they drink alcohol when
they're 15. yeah they drink coffee all
day long because my nieces are drinking
coffee now because of the coffee craze
what's the coffee craze in the united
states no i just mean no i just mean
like coffee now it's marketed like
you know like water is yeah so they're
all going to duncan and starbucks and
they're drinking coffees like you know
at age like 12 14 16. that's the thing
to do you guys shouldn't be drinking
this and they're like why and i'm like
because i think it's like not good for
you yeah i heard that it stunts your
growth we're gonna have a very short
population yeah yeah we're gonna be like
imagine america's gonna be like the
pygmy people could you
could you imagine being
14
and having
five dollars and being like i'm gonna go
spend this on coffee no when we were
here we go
yep
there's the coffee machine
thanks joe
i could do that for you if you need me
to because you do need you figured it
out look that's because you're a woman
you pick
[Laughter]
i i honestly don't believe in any shape
way shape or form he's going to do this
yeah as a matter of fact joe to prove it
i'd like you if you could to bring up
two cups for sal and i please because i
want to test this you're gonna now what
you're doing though is you're making
espresso
as a base and so you're gonna have to
dump that out and then do that three
times in order to make three of them
all right i'm gonna go on record again
and say i don't think this is gonna end
well yeah i don't think he's gonna do it
right
joe but if it's good and tastes good i
swear to god i like i'll give you the
credit like i'm not i'm being i want to
be very honest here
the beans are up
they're already in the machine you see
him
you don't have a house
what do you say he said buy him one too
yeah
i know it is it's true yeah you always
get a nice gift from sally's baby settle
down with a family buy a home and that
what that's one coming your way yeah
t minus 15 more years joey d
um
it's freaking unbelievable dude i just
want to give a quick shout out to the
tampa bay bucks oh yeah you got it too
you got the super bowl champs
by t brady t brady
unbelievable game he had the oldest guy
in the nfl do it and tampa bay it's a
home stadium never happened before
that's correct and i'd be remiss if i
didn't mention pastoral homes in the
kansas city chiefs who wants to be
remiss the best part of waking up
is patrick
congrats he's got a good bright future
ahead of him uh the whole team the
organization there is solid
patrick mahomes and the kansas city
chiefs in my opinion are the new qrik
and watson
they are they're the new quick and
watchers they're gonna be changing the
league like dna yes
yes um they do have dna uh they do have
football in their dna mm-hmm
don't they though they do have football
in their dna yeah
they do but what's interesting about dna
yeah is the spiral code of it
why are you something wild right now
nothing i want to hear more than
something wild right now when you take a
person's cells yeah and their dna and
the way it's coded two things happen
number one
all their coding for the dna is is how
they how they called it all
it's all a series of zeros and ones just
like a computer when your legs like the
matrix when you lay out somebody's dna
and all their cells in their body you
know what it looks exactly when you lay
out somebody's dna in the cells in their
body you know when they're dead you know
what it looks exactly like the stars in
the sky it looks just like the universe
it's wild when the inside of our bodies
are from the same matter that make up
the universe we are the universe we are
the world we are the champions
shout out shout out queen shout out
africa shout out to africa what a
country africa yeah in your life
are you going to go to africa yeah 100
me too yeah 100
south africa or sub-saharan
why not both yeah i'd like to give a
nice tour over there yeah what magic
mean you will go over there we'll look
for coffee get some tuna had a whole fin
that's what i want to do had a liger
yeah absolutely
it's it's no joke over there dude you
ever go safari no i know i've done six
flags i was gonna say the six flags once
it's the only one and i did i did the
safari ride at universal studios yeah so
just hold for the coffee machine please
so
so you've done the six flags um safari
and you've done would you say the one in
universal studios they have a safari or
disney one of the only so you are you
kind of get africa
i understand africa yeah i understand
africa pretty yeah and i also so is it
worth going because you've already done
the sixth floor listen i've been in
jackson new jersey here's the thing i
went to jackson new jersey i did this
right off the uh
yeah i did that and then i also i've
done that i've done done the safari ride
in in florida and then i've also sat in
a tesla elon musk from south africa i've
done africa yeah yeah yeah that's africa
you probably don't need to go i would
love you know if you go my friend went
you have to get a yellow fever shot you
have to it doesn't matter if you even
updated the v doesn't matter if you're
anti-vaxx yeah you have to get a yellow
fever shot you have to have to have to
if you allegedly if you get yellow
thieves
it's bad i never you ever meet anybody
who got like an old-school disease like
i met a person who got dysentery
and malaria they said and i met a person
who had legionnaires disease
i know all these names but i don't know
what they do he said when he got
legionnaires disease my friend one
friend said when he got legionnaires
disease he said he thought like you were
like he said you get to a point where
your body gets so sick that you just
know you're going to die he said your
brain starts to do something where it
says we're it's over oh you're going to
die like you just know and you start to
prepare for that
somebody eating away at you legionnaires
legionnaires disease i think what it
does primarily affects the lungs it can
cause infections in wounds and in other
parts of the body including the heart a
mild form is legionnaire's disease known
as uh pontiac uh
fever pontiac fever
pontiac grand am fever yeah can produce
fever chills headache and muscle i
thought that's just when you really
wanted a muscle call really bad yeah you
had pontiac fever pontiac michigan shout
out oh shout out pontiac mr pontiac
don't they make cars no more no they
don't i don't think so pontiac doesn't
make cars i don't think so neither does
saturn i that i knew i don't think
pontiac makes cars anymore unless they
were brought up by pontika
is still around is what pimpy just
now he wrote pontiac p-o-n-i-a-c
pontiac oh staten island buick can you
buy pontiac cars the gm will continue to
make parts for pontiac models
but okay so if you got a pontiac you're
those are some old school like buick is
definitely like a parent yeah you never
see a young kid with a buick no but it'd
be fun i would love to see one buick is
like the claridge
i had a buick for 15 years i had
my first call was a buick but i got it
from my parents
wow 1985 silver buick skyhawk wow 1985
fingerprints weren't even invented yet
wow holy smokes could have got stolen
with a never known holes i didn't see
footprints yes i love it all right
talking to you about draftkings which i
have on my phone i have 186.9
balance wow yeah i use it uh weekly it
helps my sundays
it gets me more into sunday football
because i got a little action going in
every game you got a little actually
going in the game draftking sportsbook
an official sports betting partner of
the nfl and with the nfl returning
draftkings is giving new customers
200 in free bets whoa instantly when you
bet one dollar or more on any football
game listen up because you don't want to
miss it absolutely dude draftkings is
what you need to do that's what tom
brady won the super bowl off draft shout
out to tommy they threw the whole game
he got a big prize on the back end of
the draftkings i'm kidding i'm kidding
draftkings but it is fun to gamble with
draftkings yeah you get the app now and
uh if you bet one dollar uh or more on
any game in uh week one then give you
two hundred dollars in credit for free
to bet instantly uh nothing adds to the
excitement of watching a game quite like
having a free shot at a million billion
dollar top prize million dollar top
prize you win that prize you're gonna
get tax on it a little bit and then you
put the rest in in bitcoin yeah that's
what you do you invest it right into
cryptocurrency right so if you download
the draftking sportsbook app right now
and use the promo code hey babe so
download it right now
okay
promo code hey babe receive 200
200
in free bets when you place a one dollar
bet on any football game you get 200
freebies and get a free shot at a
million dollar top prize with your first
deposit that's promo code hey babe for a
limited time only only at draftking
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the nfl must be 21 or older
new jersey
uh new jersey in is indiana or pa only
new customers only minimum five dollar
deposit and one dollar wager required
one per customer restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 1-800 gambler or in indiana 1 809
with it dude doordash first of all
doordash is legitimately all i use to
get food i love it i use it all the time
i mean i can't tell you how many times
i've wanted late night ice cream
how many times i've just wanted like any
type of meal pizza pasta whatever
locally how many times there's been a
couple times even when i i wanted to
cook me and me and my girl were cooking
but i forgot an ingredient doordash just
brought the ingredient that's right
because they do that now they're not
just delivering from your local
restaurant or mama pop or chain you can
go you can get now essential items
delivered to doordash drinks snacks
other household items all in under an
hour delivery service basically yeah i
know my stepmother was telling me the
other day she goes your father all he's
doing all day is on door dish all day
ordering cucumbers and i don't know
what he's doing but she was like you
know like that's what he wants to do
that's what he wants to do where you
know we live in florida now and he just
orders the cucumbers all day but
doordash brings them to them in packs
cucumbers with over 300 000 partners you
can support your neighborhood go to's or
choose from favorite national
restaurants like popeyes chipotle or
cheesecake factory cheesecake factory i
mean they might have 300 000 pages on
the menu i love it i love cheesecake
facts i know
literally i like that menu
i welcome it i like
flipping through 30 pages i will defend
cheesecake fact that's my alamo i will
defend that at all costs you will not
get the cheesecake factory and nobody's
bringing cheesecake factory to your door
the way doordash doesn't will bring it
right to your door and for a limited
time the app you download it and you
click a couple of buttons food from your
places arriving as a matter of fact
because i want why don't you download
the app and then tweet screenshots of
you downloading the app at heybaypod on
twitter do it do it forever do it
before he you heard what he said to you
do it for a limited time our listeners
can just do it
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 bucks or more when you
download the doordash app just do it and
enter code hey babe i think we should uh
i think we should trademark that just do
it just do it that's 25 off up to 10
value and zero delivery fees on your
first order when you download the
doordash app in the app store and enter
the code hey babe don't forget that's
code hey babe for 25 off your first
order with doordash subject to change
terms apply that's great dude we're
going to be so rich just do it that's
our trademark yeah that hey babe just do
it yeah great dude you know how to make
money yeah awesome get the lawyer on the
phone your dna could stretch from the
earth to the sun and back 600 times i i
think i told you that i think you were
talking intestines but pass yeah yeah
we're all 99.9 alike of the three
billion base pairs in the human genome
only point one percent are unique to us
see i told you well while that point one
percent is still what makes us unique it
means we're all more similar than we are
different oh i could smell the coffee
now it smells like a grandpa
jeans jeans make up only about three
percent of your dna
genes are short segments of dna what
else jeans make up only about three
percent of my wardrobe athleisure all
the way all the way all the way on the
absolutely same season
shout out uh bare bottom they got they
get they send all the great athleisure
and lululemon if we're being honest but
they don't want to get involved yet
um a dna test can reveal you're more
irish than your siblings okay
is that specifically your sister could
be much more irish than you i don't know
why they're going specific with the
irish and it's true for any of over 350
regions covered by the ancestry dna test
so your sibling could also be more or
less british nigerian or scandinavian
than you what
yeah i don't understand you know game of
thrones i got hot and heavy with game of
thrones during the damn during the panty
the pandemic i called the pandywean the
handywendy the pandemic the damn is
funny the dems
and uh
yeah everyone's having sex with their
families on that that's all the old
ancient world was baby i understand but
what when did it hit if
speaking of pontiac when did they hit a
fever pitch where somebody was like you
know what
i don't think you should do that
i i think that's weird and then
everybody else is like it is weird and
then because you don't know why
or did we get
we get uh medically advanced i think
they were like listen
after every single child you're having
with your cousin starts to look like a
beefalo i think that you start to say
you know what we can't
we can't do this anymore there's a clear
reason why this nature doesn't want it
what nature actually wants you know the
healthiest people the healthiest
children are the ones who are furthest
away
from from their nationality so actually
nature wants you to have sex outside of
your race right so you have a chinese
you know an asian person mixed with like
a sub-saharan african person or even
further that's the healthiest child
nature gives those those children the
least complications usually is that true
isn't that wild because you think oh you
should stay with their you're not you're
not you should but you think oh
i know right well when you think of
animals and it's always like oh this is
a purebred so and so yes they always
have more problems you always have more
products
always this is the same thing in the dog
world yes oh here we go joe's brought to
coffee
does it count if it's espresso
thank you did jazz help help you at all
this is all you
yeah cheers i'm gonna give a shout out
to your grandpa thank you up above
love you pops
yeah
as the kids would say this slaps
it's an espresso it's an espresso this
is good dude i got to tell you dude
stick with the keurig dude it's not
worth the headache you think the keurig
that just was brutal right see how long
it took yeah
you mean
you made three it took eight min nine
minutes it was it was yeah but
i make this [ __ ] in two seconds this is
freshly ground beans babe i know it's
delish but i wish there was a quick
setting on it how do you you want
freshly ground espresso made in less
than two we also like an americano
button put the pole up
water in there ground beans this is
taste buds
put the tweet the pole out right now
pimp
you you put some water in here this
becomes an americano is that all right
but how do you make coffee down there is
there an option to make coffee or that
is just an espresso machine for the
housewarming gift i'd like a coffee
machine i understand babe and you're
going to be covered in full okay thing
about the coffee machine is you got to
make a full pot that's why the curry
comes into play right the keurig right
but the coffee like i don't really drink
coffee
you just drink espresso i drink espresso
only you know what i had that was
fantastic and i make it for the
housewarming gift i will have the coffee
option you will have the coffee will it
have an iced coffee option
i think that that's up to you right you
have to put ice in it got it right makes
sense yeah the cold brew option i meant
i'm going to tell you where i'm going to
look at the latest and greatest model
with the most features and that's the
one you're going to get appreciate it
right totes appreciation yeah
you can get that machine
[Music]
you can get that machine with a coffee
pot extension you can
that's what you're saying you're saying
he's going to be no no i didn't say that
roll back the team
i'm saying i hope so no no you're saying
you're going to be fully when you said
you're going to be fully covered
yeah did by that i assumed you meant
there was a coffee addition to this
right i'm telling him well you want
first and foremost you want to be able
to make a pot of coffee is that what
you're telling me yes you have a keurig
or anything we got a cure curing is for
fast on the fly you can make one cup at
a time yeah people can self-serve you
know a whole pot because you remember
back in the day be like hey
would anyone else have coffee if so i'll
put on a pot right keurig is more like
single serve faster
if you want coffee you can just have to
call for yourself you don't have to
worry about anybody else yeah what about
brew and apato like the old school
people leaving it on there all day and
keep you keep going back to the pot the
pot stays hot on the pot warmer yeah
that's the classic way to have a coffee
that's close way to have a coffee but
this i'm telling you this is fantastic
but it's also something about the mug
too the mug i kind of feel like me it's
like drinking out of a tin mug i feel
like i'm on a ship yeah you know like
you need a little espresso cup i
couldn't find any we have them i'm sure
you do we have them they're on display
they're right there if you would have
looked if you put any effort
dude this week here's just well i got
everybody in the room this week do you
guys want to go to hershey park
no my my mom was there two days ago
i do i would go on the rides dude i mean
i there's nothing wrong there's nothing
more that i would want to do you want to
do it my mom went this week with my
nieces you guys want to go i was talking
to someone recently telling them how bad
i miss
uh theme park action like parks like
that and like carnivals and [ __ ] why
don't we just go to great adventure then
in jersey why drive all the way to
hershey park you mean in the direction
of seven eight of the turnpike you want
to go to safari why don't we go to the
safari why don't we go to africa put it
up on the page
should we should we find a free day and
go to safari i really want to do it
i really want to do it that'd be really
funny you know what the problem is with
me i don't have a passport i went to go
get a passport yesterday nine month wait
oh i'm interested nine month wait to get
a passport they know not to give one to
an animal like you dude
no i'm gonna look you up and down on the
way in the guy's like hunter yeah i have
to go under the plane
it's gonna have to be one of those
things where i don't i don't like to do
this but we're gonna have to call in
some like big connect like we're gonna
have to call someone
i'll say right now this is this is wild
because my passport expired a month ago
and i have an appointment to get a
renewal in a few days actually where i
have her appointment to get a renewal
tuesday at the guy the post office you
go to the post office
they'll initiate it but i don't know now
if you're scaring me that that'll take
eight months to process did you just
call the post office and and set it up
indeed what forms do you need
you know the form for passports you just
you don't have any you have no input i
think they can be printed out online so
but did they told you to go to cvs and
get like a passport photo you could go
to write aid yeah
yeah i could probably do it at costco
might be able to go to burlington co
factory i don't know how about pimp
takes your passport photo yeah can you
do that yeah why not
it just has some little requirements but
i'm sure you could probably know it has
to be at a licensed cvs dealer
with me yeah we should do podcasts from
the safari in the car with the mics
let's do that
i've done a mobile podcast before let's
do it let's do the position let's do the
podcast live from the safari car i'm yes
a thousand percent my only question
we're answering uh which could decide
which
because they take a wreck shop on your
on your car right the animals don't you
like wave liability when you go in there
in case a baboon just wants to fly so
you want to rent a car and do it
uh i don't know let's look into that joe
has a jeep wrangler right he does yeah
but let me ask you this babe it was a
soft top i'd be afraid to get eaten by a
giraffe you gotta tell me what happens
with the passport a giraffe is a giraffe
and a rastafarian
i'll let you know i'll let you know dude
i want to go today to six legs and do a
podcast from the safari babe should we
go to six
flags she said
oh yeah we're moving in two weeks okay
what can you do all right but but but
look at me in my eyeballs it's gonna get
done we're doing it by the way speaking
of moving how about this you've got to
move it's you know a job packing up an
apartment bringing it to a house you
know obviously you know whatever big job
i went to like you know googled online
you know went to all these all these you
know fancy companies you know they're
like two thousand dollars three thousand
dollars we'll pack it up we have state
of the art tape and this and that and
just douche bags i literally met a guy
some some russian guy owns a movie
company named sergey his cigarette out
of his mouth i told him everything we
need to do he goes five hundred dollars
i swear to god
to deal with these companies they didn't
have this date they said we can only do
between twelve and two and we only have
this date and that date and we take off
for this and that he goes what that he
goes let me check book opens up his book
he goes you're good 6 30 a.m
500 dollars you give me cash day off i
said yeah and then he go i swear to god
his cigarette hanging out he's i mean
smelled like a pack of cigarettes and he
goes uh we bring um i'm like do you have
like the specific kind of tape i heard
there's a tape you can't get in home
depot and he goes he opens like he goes
look he goes i have black tape like this
good adhesive he goes nothing break he
goes if i break anything of yours you
don't pay me i was like what
so he was like yeah he goes 500 that's
it i was gonna ask you because i was
gonna say there's no way he has
insurance but i guess that was his
insurance policy you know he said he
said he said he said i only got one
problem i said what he goes you're
moving to staten island i said yeah it
goes i have no easy pass i was like can
you just pay cash for the totes can i
give it he goes that's all's problem
it's pretty good
you bring up a good point
yeah yeah you go she's legal tender but
that's the thing it's like it's like
literally like you go through all these
like new fancy companies and they only
did online quotes and this and they're
like we make it simple and easy for you
literally the easiest thing in the world
was talking to sergey he says he but he
has no cell phone by the way he goes you
have to call my landline he goes i call
you from
i swear to god he goes he goes call me i
want to take bets pimp you call my
number he goes but you're in the book
you're in the book september 14th 6 30
a.m will be there he goes do you have
parking i said no he goes it's okay we
make i was like okay make i don't know
what he's going to do he said he's going
to make one so he's going to go to bk bk
load you up
and then in one shot did you talk about
the size of his truck
no well he i told him what we had you
know three beds or whatever and he goes
he goes like this he goes he goes i
disassemble i reassemble he goes the
only thing i don't put sheets on and we
were like we would never ask you to put
the sheets off
he goes like he's like this is where i
draw a line yeah he goes i disassemble
reassemble everything i put furniture in
and everything he goes i bring me my son
and i got two other guys
so it's three people total three people
total but the guy who i know the
basically it's the moving company of the
guy who's home of the family's home we
bought he said sergey sits in the truck
the entire move and just smoke
cigarettes oh wait it's the moving
company of the moving company so the
people's
you know who we bought the house from
it's their moving company like the movie
company that they used okay they don't
own it they use it and he was like you
know this guy when we were at the house
today that movie company was there
taking out some stuff from the guys
moving them out and you win yes i mean
she picked up a job because the guy was
like he's the best he was telling me a
story where he was like you know like
they were like literally they were
moving like this humongous china cabinet
like humongous china came and the three
guys just couldn't figure it out they
said sir he said sergey walked up the
stairs with a cigarette hanging out of
his mouth in like two moves just done
they could have done it he just pulled
like this in like this and then he
backed it all out and he said the
cigarette he said literally as soon as
one cigarette is done falls out of his
mouth he lights up another one wow yeah
he's just a workhorse workhorse all day
but he said he's in the truck
he's uh he's a real hussian
he's a russian horse russian horse yeah
yes
yes
oh he's a wars he's a roarse
okay i can't wait i would like to take
do you feel it's on the up and up do you
feel like
nothing will break do you feel like it
will be done on time for the do you do
you feel like this is going to be a 10
out of 10 a plus experience for chris
and his family i think you need to put a
tracker in a box
because if he has no cell phone he
drives off with your [ __ ] with my [ __ ]
yeah well and i also said two he goes
you have kids i said yeah i got three
little kids who goes they can drive and
truck with me if they want i was like
okay
like just joking it's like it's fun the
kids have fun with the truck wow yeah
it's great it's either gonna be awesome
or you're gonna have many problems well
the people nowhere in between the moving
that we the product the things that we
saw him moving in and out of the
previous home looked fantastic like he
wrapped it all up but how is it worth
him to get two men
and a truck for five hundred dollars i
don't know like it's that's crazy it's
just
he's gotta pay the guys maybe he owns a
lot of bitcoin some people don't do this
stuff for the money or maybe they're in
debt to him
maybe that too maybe they're not getting
maybe they're not getting any of the
money did he speak about insurance at
all he didn't speak about anything he
didn't you asked me a question about you
about insurance i didn't ask i said 500
bucks i'm in is everything he's moving
like uh
if it is there anything that's precious
to you that he's moving
like obviously you don't care when he
moves the love sack right i mean that's
no no i don't i don't really
no there's nothing precious
there's nothing precious
there's not like a piece of like you
know i don't know what like what do you
but everything else you'd take on
yourself your clothes your jewelry your
whatever the hell i'll pack that up in
boxes okay yeah i don't think yeah
there's nothing really precious
there's nothing precious are you are you
like as you go here's a little hint
because it's moving i don't know when
last time but you do it but like you you
have access to the house even now right
now so like when you come back and forth
on these little trips to like take a
look at the guy in or do this every
single time take stuff with you just
take a little every time it's just light
and strong you happen to go back and
forth 15 times in the next like you know
yeah whatever it is always take stuff
with you always right i should start
clearing out i have like a little you
know storage space i should just take
everything in that storage space that's
in bins now the winter clothes and just
put them in my trunk and just bring them
every time you come one by one i'll tell
you another and this has turned into
like very much of a martha stewart thing
now but i love you another hack i
learned myself i used it for three moves
i suggested it to a half dozen people
they sing the praises of this hack
ikea
has these blue bags there are they used
to be 50 cents each now they're like a
dollar 19 or something unbelievable they
sell them for shopping they're like
these big big like vinyl bags with these
heavy handles on them they can carry
like no joke like i swear like like 70
80 pounds a bag probably more they don't
rip i went i bought i bought 50 bags 50
yeah they're the bags are the shape of a
box they're like square bags you could
pack them like boxes but then they have
handles they're stronger than boxes you
don't have to break them down you don't
have to assemble them and tape them up
and you don't even have to label them
because you can see what's in them and
they stack they're all cheaper than
buttons you can google the ikea bags
just so i know which ones i want to get
classifications more durable than boxes
they store away much smaller than box
you could put all 50 in a little box
themselves this one the ikea blue bag
oh that's it which one they're all the
same ones 12.75
so now no no that's got to be for a case
of them you go to ikea right now in
elizabeth new jersey they're a dollar
each what if i want to go to the one in
brooklyn that's dope somebody took the
bag and made a friggin
bolo it made i made up i made a fedora
fedora out of it that's high fashion you
want the ikea fedora yeah dude i'm
telling you someone get those bags
do you have any bags left over from your
last move
every time someone moves i've given them
like all the bags and they give me back
but i always lose like five in the
transaction i might have like i want my
housewarming gift in the bag i might
like have 20 downstairs i'm telling you
dude
and then also to pack them it's just
like throw it in the bag throw it in the
bag it doesn't matter it's just easy and
it's a dollar so you don't you don't
care like you can make a trip right now
and just fill a bag with nonsense but
then you could dude it's it's so much
back on this podcast and yesterday it
changed my life
and ikea if you're watching and we know
that you are and people start to catch
on to this and it's a thing
something has to come my way seriously
at least a meatball something yes
yes okay the ikea bags all right that's
good that's good now why did you bring
up sexual relations or cohabitation
involved you guys were talking about uh
like pretty much incest so these are the
states that allow first cousin marriage
what
so you can marry your first cousin in
alaska marriage hold on the first
column's marriage the second is
sexual relations you can have sex with
your first cousin
but you cannot marry them oh my god you
could have sex with your first cousin in
almost every state california can marry
and have sex with your first cousin the
only hold on we just looked at 20 states
the only state that says no right now is
arizona and delaware
no no but you could have sick the right
the right column is sexual relations and
cohabitation just not marriage look at
illinois
in illinois you can marry them only if
both parties are 50 and older or one is
infertile
so if you're in love with your cousin
you're waiting till their 50th birthday
yeah wow in indiana you have to be 65 oh
my god
oh my god wow kentucky is just no one
knows so you think you would think
kentucky you would think kentucky would
be like
yeah the south actually the south yeah
you cannot marry your first cousin and
you can't have sex with them or
cohabitate but right now the only two
states that you can't have sex with your
first cousin in legally is arizona and
kentucky
look at maine
proof of genetic counseling from a
genetic counselor
who's it okay
in minnesota only just the only dead the
only instructions from minnesota on
whether you can marry a first cousin or
not is you could only marry certain
types holy [ __ ] does that mean so yeah
if you're both type a personality can't
do it mississippi says no on the sex so
all the south says no
you are illegally allowed to have sex
with your first cousin in so far 47
states new york yes and yes new jersey
in new york you could have and marry
is there a first cousin you're in love
with that is weird weird
oh that's disgusting wow north dakota
the only state to say no to both
no there's a bunch of states that said
no to both both
kentucky and north carolina says yes
except in the rare case of double first
cousins what is a double first cousin
please google double first because
this is francis and crick stuff right
here this is dna discovering double
first cousins dna comes from the same
source but not directly from a shared
parent
i don't understand it is still the same
amount of dna because all grandparents
are the same dna comes from the same
source but through all grandparents
can you explain it to
explain i'm in a double first cousins
what's a double first cousin
yeah i don't i didn't understand that
did you yeah
no not the genomes unzip when you get
into the i just need somebody to explain
it like i'm stupid so a first cousin is
when siblings double first cousins for
dummies first cousin is when siblings
have children
right a first cousin their own children
that's your first cousin yes so maybe a
first
a double first cousin is when
two
siblings
two s
two siblings have a baby
no
when two siblings from one family marry
two siblings from another family then
their children are double first cousins
double first cousins share both sets of
grandparents and are as genetically
related as half siblings i understand so
if you're if you and your sister if you
and your sister yeah married
married me and my sister okay
if your sister married me and you
married my sister we have kids and we
have kids our kids are double first
cousins
because
right right because we're in the same
family because we're both marrying in
the city i got my sisters whenever two
siblings marry another when two families
when they basically
basically yeah like like you're marrying
into the same family like if you're
sister you're because so so so if i
marry your sister right then our child
is you're their uncle
but then my sister
is both their aunt because she's married
to you but also because she's my sister
yes
so it's a dublay this has been hey babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey